c'est une dangereuse escalade qui à
laquelle on assiste aujourd'hui en
méditerranée puisque la situation est
extrêmement tendue
surtout depuis que monsieur le présent
erdogan a décidé d'envoyer un bateau
d'exploration sismique en méditerranée
et que la france lui a répondu en
envoyant un avis sur zone pour faire
respecter le droit maritime
international
il est aujourd'hui en train de nouer une
véritable alliance politique avec les
nationalistes et donc on assiste à une
convergence entre les islamistes et les
nationalistes pour faire que la turquie
devienne l'un des acteurs régionaux du
moyen orient et de la méditerranée qui
doit devenir incontournable surtout dans
la perspective du centenaire de
l'anniversaire des accords de cendre et
de lausanne qui ont contribué à
démembrer l'empiré ottoman en 1923 donc
la perspective géographique et
chronologique pour le président erdogan
c'est la date symbolique de 2023